hey 42 here the Advent of the internet
has changed Human Society in many ways
both good and bad on the plus side sites
like Wikipedia Google and YouTube have
given us entirely new ways to learn
online stores have revolutionized the
way we shop and social media has
reminded us how important it is to make
other people think that our lives are
way better than they actually are on the
flip side the internet has also provided
a platform for basement gnomes to gather
and share absolutely mental conspiracy
theory
did you know that some people genuinely
believe the war in Iraq was orchestrated
to prevent Saddam Hussein from using a
Stargate to start an Intergalactic
war or what about the people who think
the large hajun collider at CERN was
built not to study Physics but to summon
an Egyptian
god flat earthers I'm still on the fence
about I know their ideas are a little
radical but can so many people really be
wrong I mean seriously there are quite
literally hundreds of thousands of flat
earthers spread all around the
globe wait a minute arguably the most
ridiculous conspiracy theory out there
claims that planet Earth is currently
being run by a master race of
shape-shifting blood drinking aliens now
I'll admit there are a few people in
positions of power who could probably
pass vilis of men under the right
lighting but it should be obvious to
anyone with a fully functioning brain
that Earth isn't ruled by highly int ENT
lizards at least not anymore because
according to something called the soran
hypothesis there's a chance that lizard
men were indeed in charge at some point
in the distant
past named after an ancient race of
intelligent reptiles from British TV
series Doctor Who the soran hypothesis
was published in the international
Journal of astrobiology in 2018 by Gavin
Schmidt a British climatologist and
American astrophysicist Adam Frank
but whilst the name of the paper is
straight out of sci-fi the science
behind it is deadly serious at its heart
the soran hypothesis is based on a
simple question were we humans the first
Advanced civilization to exist on
Earth now I know what you're thinking of
course we bloody were but before we dump
the soran hypothesis into the Looney Bin
along with reptilian conspiracy theory
let me rephrase that question if there
was an advanced civilization on Earth
that died out millions of years ago how
would we know and don't say because we
would have found a dinosaur with a noia
3310 up its ass because as it happens
there's a good chance we
wouldn't the soran hypothesis may be
named after fictional lizard people but
this hypothetical ancient civilization
could have been anything over hominids
ancient Dolphins squid people even
manur it might seem unlikely that
humanlike intelligence evolved millions
of years before we did but there's no
reason it shouldn't have we have a bad
habit of thinking humans represent the
Pinnacle of evolution that we're a kind
of end state that life has been striving
towards for the last three and a half
billion years but that isn't how
Evolution works there is no end goal and
no spe species is more evolved than any
other intelligence is just an
evolutionary adaptation that comes with
its pros and cons and it's evolved many
times in many different forms on Earth
given the right circumstances there's no
reason highly intelligent species
couldn't have evolved in the distant
past according to Schmitt and Frank
there has been enough fossil fuel on
Earth to power a civilization like our
own since the aptly named Carboniferous
period about 350 million years ago so
it's possible that another intelligent
species evolved on Earth in the distant
past and if one did it would have had
enough fossil fuels on top to build a
world spanning industrial
civilization intuitively you might be
thinking that if that indeed did happen
we'd probably have noticed by now but it
turns out you can sweep an awful lot of
history under a 300 50 million year old
carpet we know about ancient
civilizations like the Incas Mayans and
Romans because of the artifacts they
left behind we can dig up their pottery
and coins or find traces of their long
lost settlements buried in the soil in
some cases we don't even need to dig
because the evidence is just sitting
around on the surface like at Stonehenge
or Machu
Picchu when viewed in the context of the
length of a human life Earth might seem
like a fairly stable place but on a
geological time scale things look very
different mountains rise and fall
volcanoes spe for enough lava to bury
entire continents oceans dry up or shift
position and the combined forces of the
wind rain snow and ice brutally scour
every inch of the planet's surface and
we can't forget the Relentless grind of
plate tonics which ultimately removes
and recycles the very ground upon which
we stand traces of ancient civilizations
might linger for hundreds of thousands
of years after the civilization that
made them
disappears but over a period of millions
of years even mighty monuments like the
pyramids at Giza will be ground into
dust the very same will be true of our
own monuments and cities when chat GPT
goes Rogue and murders everyone
according to Smith and Frank after about
4 million years all direct physical
evidence of a globe spanning industrial
civilization like ours would be utterly
gone it's hard to believe from our
limited human perspective but if we all
disappear tomorrow 5 million years from
now aliens could colonize Earth and
never even realize we
existed okay so we wouldn't necessarily
find out about an ancient civilization
by diing up their long lost cities or
artifacts what about fossils the oldest
fossils cyanobacteria date back almost
to the dawn of life
itself and the oldest animal fossils are
almost 900 million years
old If there really was a globe spanning
civilization of intelligent creatures
right here on Earth wouldn't we have
found their fossils by now maybe but
probably not fossils only form under
very specific specific conditions there
are multiple factors involved but most
importantly the organism in question
needs to be completely buried in an
oxygen-free environment soon after death
that's far more likely to happen in some
environments than others which creates
natural biases in the fossil record for
example we know relatively little about
ancient species that live predominantly
in mountain or jungle environments
because those ecosystems rarely produce
fossils mountainous regions are
dominated by erosion rather than de
position I and jungles are full of
scavengers that constantly turn over the
soil by far the most common place for
fossils to form is in the ocean because
animals that die there often end up at
the very bottom where they might get
buried in oxygen por sand or
mud for that reason a staggering 99% of
all fossils come from marine animals but
even there things are skewed for example
soft body creatures like jellyfish and
Squid Almost Never
fossilize what I'm trying to say is that
the fossil record is an amazing window
into the past but like my chest hair
it's embarrassingly patchy thanks to the
inherent Rarity of fossilization it's
thought that only around
0.1% of all the species that ever lived
are represented in the fossil record the
over
99.9% we're talking several billion
species are just G we have no way of
knowing what they were or when and how
they
lived in other words if there was an
advanced civilization on Earth millions
of years ago we certainly couldn't rely
on fossils to identify them and if we
couldn't detect them in the fossil
record or by finding the remains of
their artifacts and cities we would have
no way of knowing they existed at all or
would we it's true that we might not be
able to directly detect an ancient
civilization by finding bits of them or
the things that they left behind but the
there may be another way to track them
down by using ourselves as a model we
humans aren't just building cities
motorways and new Starbucks everywhere
we're also fundamentally changing the
makeup of our planet we're burning
fossil fuels which is Shifting the
balance of carbon Isotopes in the
atmosphere we're re-rooting the nitrogen
cycle of the entire planet through the
use of industrial fertilizers we're
digging up vast quantities of rare Earth
elements for use in electronics
and we're dumping plastic into the
oceans at a rate of about 14 million
tons per year global temperatures are
rising sea levels are rising Coastal
erosion is rising and oceanic oxygen
levels are falling and we've possibly
just triggered our planet's six major
Extinction
event yeah to summarize we're causing
absolute bloody Mayhem and much of this
madness will eventually be recorded in
the rocks that will one day make up the
human era also known as the amrop pasine
in the geological
record if millions of years from now a
sufficiently advanced species was to
study this Amrine layer in Earth's rock
strata they wouldn't need to call sure
Rock homes to see that some long dead
species had had one hell of a house
party and never cleaned up after itself
even industrial civilization similar to
our own once lived here on Earth they
probably would have left behind a techno
signature in rocks from their era that
will resemble the ones we're in the
process of creating right now and here's
where things get really interesting
because it turns out we've already found
one the geological record tells us
that's about 55.5 million years ago in a
period known as the paleocene eosine
thermal maximum or PM Earth went through
some serious
changes the ratio of atmospheric carbon
isotop shifted dramatically global
temperatures and sea levels Rose sharply
and oceanic oxygen levels plummeted
sound familiar there was even a mass
extinction event similar to the one some
scientists say we're experiencing
now scientists are pretty confident that
all these changes were caused by a
massive release of fossil carbon into
the atmosphere but they can't seem to
figure out where all that carbon came
from but interestingly enough one kind
of animal seems to have avoided this
mass extinction event entirely during
the petm lizards appear to have thrived
so lizard men confirmed right sadly
probably not whilst nobody knows exactly
what caused the petm scientists are
after unanimous opinion that it wasn't
blood drinking gizzards I know shock the
most popular theory is that it was
caused by either a massive volcanic
event a comet impact or the release of
massive quantities of methane
sequestered beneath the ocean
floor the petm might not be the
handiwork of a long lost intelligent
civilization but it does highlight a
really important Point even if an
ancient civilization did leave behind
some kind of techn signature within
Earth's rocks identifying it won't be
easy after all it's hard to draw
definitive conclusions about what
happened tens of millions of years ago
by studying 2 cm of old rock we're also
making plenty of assumptions about what
exactly we're looking for something a
bit like us basically if our
hypothetical ancient civilization did
things slightly differently particularly
if they didn't rely heavily on fossil
fuels then we've got no chance of
finding them the same will be true if
they died out before reaching their own
version of the Industrial Revolution an
ancient Society similar to our own in
the Middle Ages would have left no Trace
whatsoever ultimately the Solan
hypothesis isn't really about proving
whether or not we were Earth's first
major civilization it's a force
experiments designed to get us pondering
the possibility Smith and Frank
themselves have made it clear they think
it's highly unlikely that an advance
civilization is lurking down the back of
the giant sofa that is our planet's long
history but their work has proven we
can't rule it out perhaps evidence of
some unimaginably Advanced prehistoric
species is out there buried somewhere
beneath our feet just waiting for us to
unearth it it wouldn't be the first time
either let me tell you why if you travel
back in time 200 years or so and asked a
random person on the street whether
giant hundreds ton reptiles once roamed
the Earth they'd probably have burnt you
at the
stake the first dinosaur fossils weren't
recognized until the early 19th century
and the word dinosaur didn't even exist
until
1842 evidence proving the existence of
dinosaurs is all over the place on all
seven of Earth's continents we simply
didn't have the technology or the
understanding to see what it
was will the same be true for lizard men
I bloody hope so thanks for watching
just a quick word to say that I couldn't
make these videos without the support of
my patreon members consider joining the
exclusive 42 Discord Community by
supporting me on patreon it's a great
place to discuss my videos with
like-minded individuals and myself the
Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you